days at 6 45 a.m eastern time
[Music]
this is book notes c-span 60-minute
discussion with the authors of public
policy historical and political works
for the next hour you'll see behind the
titles and gain insight into the authors
as people and the experiences which
shape their lives
this week our guest is derek bell former
law professor at harvard university he
joins us to discuss his book faces at
the bottom of the well the prominence of
racism
[Music]
derek bell author of faces at the bottom
of the well what's the title mean
i think black people are the faces at
the bottom of the societal well
that
whites most of whites in america who are
only one level above also denied
opportunity also oppressed in a certain
way
are fascinated in looking down on us
rather than looking back at the top to
see where the
folk at the top are manipulating both
groups
only if they
in effect
let down their ropes
join with us can both groups ever climb
up and challenge
and confront those at the top who make
all the money who have all the
opportunity and some do
but most seem fascinated simply making
sure that we stay below them
and it's a uh
kind of a metaphor that it seems
reflects
much of what has happened in the history
of race in our society and it's the
challenge
that faces our society and it is the
reason
because thus far that challenge has
never been effective
that i conclude that racism is a
permanent part of the american scene
based on your experience of being
interviewed a lot for this book
what would this may sound like a strange
question to you but what what kind of
question is a white male
am i more likely to ask you in the next
hour than if i were a black male
what my publisher said martin kessler
who has really supported me with this
book and the earlier version the earlier
book that's like this one
there he said
your book is unremittingly despairing
and i get that question again and again
uh very few blacks would ask that though
some some do particularly professional
civil rights people
and they mean that gee racism is
permanent where does that leave us
but most blacks say
yes it is
now let's deal with that thank you for
saying it you see
because if you really are
a part of this thing you really sense
where you are regardless of how much
money you may make and what have you
that you are part of a group that's at
the bottom of the societal well
then any truth any insight about your
status is not despairing because the
truth is not despairing when you see it
as the truth
in fact it's it's almost enlightening
because you say ah
that's what it is it's not this thing
over here it's not this thing over here
and so that the
i i was on a very controversial talk
show host
uh and he kept pressing me and pressing
me why are you so disappearing look what
this is going to do and he opened the
line for phone calls and a couple of
obviously black people called in and
hailed what i was saying in the book and
took
the
white host to task
for challenge me why don't you listen to
him they said you see
so that the book is the other question
is who did you write this for
and the answer is that i wrote it for
both blacks and whites uh not simply
lawyers although in law students
although many of those stories initially
were initiated as challenges in the
classroom
but for blacks it was to provide this
enlightenment
to give a different sense of where they
are of what is the cause of the
sense of subordination that they feel
and they experience and it is also to
say to whites that racism is in its
permanence is not a condemnation of you
but rather a a challenge to you to
recognize that you too are victimized by
this unless you're at the very top of
this system and even then uh the crime
that afflicts our communities that is
mostly black crime is not limited to
black people uh you see and so that
there is something there for all of us
but it is not what gunner myrtle felt it
is not what most of us felt when i went
to law school
uh this sense was brown was decided two
years before i graduated
and the world generally felt
knowledgeable people experienced people
that well with brown decided with uh
discrimination based in law being
condemned by the supreme court
it was all over all we needed was
enforcement uh sort of a rear guard
action to take care of the folk who
were persistent and hardliners
but i was told that i was born 15 years
too late to be a civil rights lawyer you
see and well now we we see that that was
wrong that that was far far too
optimistic and the question i've been
asking and i have the luxury as a law
teacher to be able to step back uh that
i didn't have as a litigator that i
didn't have as an administrator to step
back look
what keeps these patterns going again
and again in different forms but
continuing over 200 years
and it seemed to me that the conclusions
that i found from that question
led to
the the title of that book that racism
is a permanent part of the american
scene where's hometown pittsburgh
pennsylvania
it's interesting
when i grew up in the 30s and the 40s
segregation was a way of life in the
south by
hard rigid law
in the north and pits places like
pittsburgh by a general understanding
black people did not go there you didn't
seek jobs there or a level above
above the bottom
uh
i delivered newspapers throughout my
junior and senior high school years and
in the black community
and within eight ten blocks
every every socio-economic level
from the one black judge in the city to
one of the few black lawyers all the way
down to people on welfare to the
unemployed to maids and janitors and
what have you
and the two lawyers were models
for me and the people who had halfway
decent jobs were stabilizers in that
community they they
their houses were a little uh
nicer they were made brick instead of
frame but they all live in the same
community and they insisted that there
be decent police protection that the
streets be cleaned that the broken
lights be repaired and what have you as
middle-class people do regardless of
race car and creed today under the the
new scheme
that i as a civil rights lawyer help
bring into being we have equal
opportunity one of the things that is
meant is that those folks who were able
the lawyers who were models for me no
longer live for the most part in the
inner city they have moved out to the
suburbs which is their right but they
are not available to our inner city
youth whose models too often are the
drug dealers and and the pimps and the
and the other people who whose modeling
is is something less praiseworthy than
any of us would hope where'd you get
your undergraduate degree one school
right in pittsburgh
duquesne university for undergraduate
and the university of pittsburgh law
school
your parents did what my father was a
janitor he had about a sixth grade
education he came here from alabama
never went back i think late in his life
of relativity had was fond of
died and i think he made his first trip
back but he never wanted to talk about
it
and he came up during the depression
married my mother who had high school
education the family hoped that she was
going on to college didn't happen there
was great disappointment there
and i was one of the first of
four children my father developed
narcolepsy at a fairly early age didn't
know very much about it
the doctors told him he had to get
outside work so he had he left his job
as a janitor in a department store
and started his rubbish hauling business
that he really built into a fairly
successful business so that by black
standards we were fairly middle class
and
they provided me with models i tell the
story about my mother
who i remember at an early age when we
were
just you know not barely above welfare
my father worked as a laborer
and i remember
she taking my brother and i to the local
rent office not too far a short walk
from our home going in going into her
pocketbook bringing out the rent money
and waving it at the man behind the
little cage and saying i have my rent
and you will get it when you send
somebody out to fix the backs there so
my kids won't fall and hurt themselves
and
i thought later i didn't realize at the
time i thought oh my god they could have
kicked us out and made sure that we
didn't find another place to live
but that didn't happen rather the man
sent somebody out and fixed our back
steps and fixed the back steps of
everybody along that row of houses
you see she took the risk she confronted
them with which what she thought was
clearly a wrong a danger and it worked
and that's been my experience in life
that
that you don't always have to sit down
and you can't confront everything that
happens to you but that you there's some
things that you can stand up for and
it's risky but it but but things work
out where are your three siblings
um my brother teaches um
at a school in new york
he's a musician
but he hasn't he's earned his living
mainly as a teacher at a college in new
york i have a sister who's a teacher in
akron ohio and another sister who's a
works in civil service in in pittsburgh
can you remember and you mentioned the
judge in your community can you remember
who who was it that
got you really interested in being a
lawyer yeah yeah i still remember he was
homer s brown i think he was the first
black judge in western pennsylvania
and and his brother-in-law as a matter
of fact we live right next door to him
and i remember his name everett
utterback
both now deceased but both of them i you
know i was a young kid but i didn't
recognize that they lived in homes
beautiful much
handsomer than mine or most of those on
my route that their houses were built to
brick rather than frame that their wives
were handsome and intelligent
individuals that they invited maybe in
that they always paid their bills on
time
and it was very impressive
i learned from them that that you
impress by example much more than by uh
what you say and you you met them
delivering paper delivering papers did
you did you uh and then we had a
dialogue oh yes often enough they would
ask me how my grades were and what i
wanted to do with my life and
what about going into law and what
opportunities i of course was interested
in being an
aeronautical engineer
but i had no models who were
aeronautical engineers in the in in the
40s and early 50s
my math skills were horrible
as they are for many people who decided
maybe i better go to law school
and
and so that these i look back now and
these were people who influenced me a
great deal did you have both black and
white customers
a few whites but the community was
mainly mainly black when in your life do
you remember the first
racial slight or racism example
you know it was
not during my childhood i knew there
were things
you could tell race my parents used to
say
um
you have to work twice as hard as a
black person to get half as much my
mother would say that at all times but
there was kind of a respect my father
would say you know
white people are are scheming and
planning while we're sleeping and eating
eating
and you tell you that was a message my
mother would say
uh when i go downtown and i see a lot of
white women around a particular counter
i dive right in there because they must
know something right you get all of
these kind of very interesting
things i mean we used to listen to amos
and andy and laugh a lot i mean you knew
it was stereotype and it was demeaning
but heck those were only black
characters on on on radio and the amos
and andy radio were whites and they said
television that's right that's right uh
but you kind of accepted whatever wings
over jordan was a radio program that
came on every morning it was a black
choir singing spirituals and that was
diva gore i remember being able to
walk up the street on sunday morning
some
nice day windows open long before air
conditioning particularly in the black
community and you'd never miss a beat
because all the radio stations uh were
tuned to wings over jordan
and some of your listeners uh watchers
will prob viewers will probably remember
that
what about uh in just normal day-to-day
life where do you see
racism what kind of thing
your question was and i didn't really
answer it is that uh in my early i
didn't see it directly we didn't try to
go to restaurants my mother talked about
work working as a dishwasher in a
downtown restaurant where blocks didn't
didn't go to eat my parents didn't go
out to a restaurant i don't think ever
when there was one little black
restaurant in the in in the black
community but for the most part i don't
think we ever went there
when i grew up and went to law school i
remember my first job wasn't here in
washington and i my parents came down to
visit and i took them out to a
restaurant and i remember them being
visibly
ill at ease my father in particular
later it eased up but this was a new
experience for them you see but
the direct
racial insults i was kind of insulated
from in the growing up in the black
community
in the schools i'm sure that there was
discrimination but i was a star student
and i was treated very uh treated very
well
now when was the first time that you
you know the you saw racism out of
school that you that made you
uncomfortable i guess when i i went to
college i went to duquesne i was in rotc
it was during the korean war
and my and of course as soon as i
finished i was got my orders to to take
active duty status and i was going to
report to a base in south carolina
for orientation and what have you my
father was visibly disturbed
and he had just gotten a new car
plymouth
and he said you take this car and you
can make the payments for anyone have
you which is what i did and so you don't
have to ride these segregated trains
down there
well i i
visibly upset him because i asked one of
my white classmates at the from the
college who was also ordered to report
to
south carolina to drive along with me
well and that's what we did
and i remember i knew that we couldn't
stay i couldn't stay at the white places
but i got the name of a
black rooming house in virginia and we
were going down below washington and we
were going to stop there for the night i
think it was in richmond
and when the two of us walked up to the
woman's door
she was very unhappy
he she said cannot stay here
um and i drove him to a white hotel
and
then i came back and she let me stay but
she lectured me i was going to get her
in trouble and such and such and stuff
and
even that
i came to know that this was a different
world
when i got to south carolina and then
later was stationed in louisiana
at an air base there and i was living in
town
because they said there was no room for
me in bachelor offices quarters there
was plenty of room they just didn't want
me to stay there
i came to realize that wow my life
was always at risk that any white person
could knock me down and what have you
that didn't happen but that was the
first time i realized that it could
happen and i really had no recourse
well i tell you i wore my uniform a
great deal
and
i felt comfortable and got better
treatment
but there was still discrimination if i
wanted to go to the movies i had to sit
upstairs
i decided i was presbyterian at that
time and there was no black presbyterian
church so i went to the local white
presbyterian church one morning
and presented myself in the door with my
uniform my bar shining
and the
usher came very nervous
good morning lieutenant i said good
morning i would like to attend service
oh very good
oh wait a minute he said and he went
back and he conferred with all of him
and came back and said uh we will only
welcome you would you mind sitting
upstairs
i said does the surface come up there he
said oh yes sir yes it does so i went up
there and obviously this is an old stage
church and all the people had their own
pews but that morning i had plenty of
room
but an old woman came tottering up to me
afterwards put out her hand and said
welcome i'm glad you're here
and i went back and each sunday people
kind of returned to the seats that they
had been sitting in for uh for for years
and i felt fairly comfortable
and finally asked the minister about
singing in the choir
well this was visibly upsetting to him
and he said he would have to think about
it and what have you well i don't know
whether he called the base commander or
what have you but i'd also been
complaining to the base commander about
the segregation of the buses the bus
could be integrated as it went around
the bus but when it got to the gate
the bus driver pulled over and blacks
workers and service people would have to
move to the back
uh and i thought that was crazy
and a few things like that and next
thing you knew i was ordered to go to
korea
so but that that period was the first
time i really
experienced the
what many blacks know about very very
well on a day-to-day and i don't i'm
jumping away ahead but on a day-to-day
basis where do you see racism in your
life today here what are the little
things that you yeah vibes that you get
i went to
lunch yesterday at union station which
has been totally revamped and very
popular and a lot of sort of al fresco
restaurants around and we went and
stopped for lunch
and
very good service but as i looked about
i saw that all the waiters were white
and all the busboys were asian
here in a community with what population
70 80 black
not a black waiter in sight
as a matter of fact i don't think i've
seen a black waiter in a restaurant
since i've been here the last two or
three days and
i've eaten in a number of restaurants
when i came here in
1957 right out of law school
there were a number of downtown
restaurants that only had black waders
you see the restaurants had only
recently been desegregated
and it shows the difference in pa in
their patterns so that while we now have
a black mayor
um black city council people which would
of course been
ridiculous even to contemplate back in
the in the late 50s
that the patterns
are such that the
the mainstream of blacks are more
limited in job opportunities perhaps
than was the case then
and in patterns that are existing laws
and we have more civil rights laws on
the books than we've ever had but those
laws are aimed at a
kind of discrimination a kind of blatant
overt
no negroes hired kind of thing then we
simply don't have any more
uh what we're dealing with today is a is
a kind of uh um
racial preference uh racial priority a
racial nepotism
in which there's this for one reason or
another a preference for them that
doesn't mean that i'll i'll never find a
black waiter at a restaurant but it
means that i won't find very many not
because the owners and managers hate
black people because they'll serve me
every time you see uh in other blacks
who are well dressed and look like
they're able to pay the bill
but there are a number of reasons why
they don't want blacks as waiters or
they don't want blacks at this level or
they don't want blacks or maybe only one
so that while prior to brown prior to
the ending of official discrimination uh
racism was blatant
and open
and and and stark
um
you you knew why you were not being
hired or admitted or rented to and what
have you
you knew who the enemy was
it was not you
but today the patterns are more confused
when you're turned down
you're not sure whether with the old
discrimination at work or whether
there's some inadequacy because the
society is filled
with explanations and rationales why
it's your fault and people kind of grasp
onto that
a caller in one of the radio talk shows
i was on the other day called and said
that
he he appreciated discrimination but now
obviously white collar he was concerned
because someone had told him that back
in africa when the slave trade was going
on that some africans participated and
assisted the
uh slave traders in procuring
capturing africans and selling them off
into slavery
and i said that's right that did happen
why is that
so what
well he said if that's the case i don't
see why white people have to feel guilty
about everything that happened because
blacks participated in it you see
well that seems crazy but it it it
indicates the extent
to which there is sort of a search for
justifications uh for rationalizations
for anything that get spoke off the hook
that make it unnecessary that for them
to deal with this to accept
responsibility to try to
struggle with it
not everyone but the patterns are there
uh that the
and and it's so interesting that's why
clarence thomas
gets promoted to the supreme court any
black who is willing to stand in a
public place
and say that welfare
is the fault of lazy blacks including
his own sister any black who's willing
to say that affirmative action
is all bad
not that it simply has some aspects that
are that are not positive
any black who is willing to
say what many whites think with regard
to why blacks aren't getting ahead
immediately shoots forward because that
person is a comfort
to the society
the other part of that though
and why this is such a crazy thing is
that i am with all my uh supposed
militants
as much a comfort for the society
because uh whites look at me and say boy
you're talking bad about racism okay
okay but you're black
you must have faced racism
let and yet you made it
why can't the other blacks be like you
when you got out of the military did you
come to washington then no i went to law
school
and after law school you came here and
when i got a i graduated probably about
fourth in my class at duquesne at the
university of pittsburgh i'm sorry yeah
and i was the only black in my class and
had a lot of good friends and
obviously i was able to gain respect to
my classmates because i was i was
smarter than most of them what it is i
wrote better than most most of them and
that's key in traditional illegal legal
education writing skills that you gain
without any
help from the legal education process
are are very important to being able to
do to do to do well in any event i
started hearing my classmates talk about
this law firm and the other law firm
nobody had contacted me about any of
those and i remember one of the biggest
law firms called out to the school and
said we generally hire from harvard and
yale but we send down your top four or
five people i went down there and
presented myself and then you know
people almost had heart attacks and
finally the big partner called me and
said you know we'd never thought about
hiring a black i'll have to think about
it and he called me back a couple weeks
later and said well we thought about it
but we're not ready
you see
during the end of that story is the um
william rogers who was then the
associate general uh um
[Music]
attorney general
came as our law review speaker i was
editor associate editor-in-chief of the
law review
and i think some of the faculty said
well bell is having a hard time getting
a job
and he uh
offered me a position in the attorney
general's honor graduate program that
had started a few years ago and i and i
accepted that job what was did you meet
him oh yes directly yes did he interview
you no he didn't he just asked me did i
where was i interested
and i said i was i applied and i was
almost immediately accepted so it's
clear he sent the word word down it's
clear that some of the faculty had
spoken to him about the fact that i was
almost at the top of the class and yet
had no job and you came to washington i
came to the justice department
how long i stayed about a year and a
half then what i was in i'd gotten a
transfer into the new civil rights
division
that was established under the civil
rights act of 1957.
shortly thereafter
the
supervisors of that position called me
in and said that i'd have to resign my
membership in the naacp because they saw
it as a conflict of interest
i told them i was not a policy maker or
anything i had a two dollar membership
they were very insistent and we went
back and forth but i finally decided
that rather than give up my membership i
would resign from the
from the position which i did where'd
you go went back to pittsburgh and a
woman who i used to deliver her paper
was stepping down as the executive
director of the pittsburgh branch naacp
and urged me to take that job which i
did
while i was there during that year
thurgood marshall came through speaking
then
director council of the naacp legal
defense fund
and thurgood said boy
which what's a lawyer doing in a
non-lawyer job
and before i could even explain he said
why don't you come and join join me in
new york which i did with great speed
and it's so interesting
that i i always suspected this but i saw
thurgood not too long ago
and he indicated that bill hasty the
late the first federal budget good
friend of circuits was on the
board and had urged thurgood to hire me
and so when he came through pittsburgh
that's why i got the got the offer so
that by by sticking to what i thought
were my principles with regard to the
justice department i put myself in a
position to get in
uh to the legal defense fund which many
lawyers particularly black lawyers would
would have given up anything to do how
long did you stay there i stayed about
five years
and then i returned to
washington during the heyday of the
johnson administration william gardner
was secretary of hew i mean john gardner
john gardner that's right thank you
and
worked as deputy director of the office
for civil rights nhew and that was a
period when we were
desegregating schools by threatening to
cut off federal uh financial assistance
and that was a fairly exciting uh
uh fairly exciting era how long did you
stay there about two years
and then i'd been interested in teaching
and a very good friend a very well-known
law teacher had sent letters out to the
major schools
and either they hadn't replied or they
wrote back some condescending
response indicating they weren't
interested
but
the university of southern california
was starting a
a poverty law center
and
one of the organizers one of the faculty
members called and asked whether i'd
like to be the director and i said well
i'm really interested in teaching
and they also they attached to the job
an adjunct
position so that i could teach one
course and i accepted it and moved to
california
and during my two years there
martin luther king was killed in the
spring of 1968 and as you remember there
were great disruptions and riots
throughout the several months later
and many institutions many corporations
many government agencies decided in
response to those rights that well maybe
nothing has much has happened since
brown maybe we need to open up and see
can't we bring in one block here one
black there and harvard was one of those
places so by that time i'd been turned
down by harvard not once but twice i had
applied myself
once while i was up
giving a lecture
and
now suddenly harvard was very interested
what reasons did they give you the first
two times and not hire you
the second the first time i didn't get
the response the other this the law
teacher
just weren't interested and when i
applied directly they said they had no
openings with for someone with my
expertise well by that time i'd been
litigating i'd been administering this
program what i didn't have was a harvard
degree
near the top of the class
and a clerkship
at the supreme court level and the
individual whose class i taught was a
young teacher who i had met because he
was following around monitoring my work
for the justice department who had no
experiences of his own but had gone to
harvard had clerked at the supreme court
level and therefore had their credential
so he came back and said well
we don't have any openings for someone
with your expertise so i said okay but
two years later
after all of the events the
assassination the riots suddenly they
were very interested in me both harvard
and a number of the other major major
schools and i was i subsequently was
offered and accepted a position at
harvard but for me to go to that
position and think that it was simply my
talents
and not the circumstances
would be crazy
i saw
that i was an illustration of a pattern
as old as racial history
that the fact that i felt deserving of
an offer there was simply not enough
they had to sense that there was
something of value to them
something of their own interests before
they were willing to take a risk with me
i risked both in terms of being the
first black there and also as far as i
can see the first person who they had
hired who didn't have their credentials
and so my pioneering the barriers that i
had to overcome were twofold one is the
first black with all the presumptions of
black incompetence that in our that our
society
places on blackness and also all the
presumptions of non-worthiness
that many of the folk many of the
faculty there had because i was i didn't
come along the route that they that they
came what year did you begin teaching at
harvard 1969
and i was tenured in 1971.
it's it's only two years but older
people i was 38 at the time
are given a shorter period uh in which
to
for them
to make a decision whether to place you
on a permanent faculty
your book yes now uh before i want to
ask you about chapter seven as a way of
talking more about the harvard
experience a law professor's protest
but before we do that what technique
have you used in this book fiction and
non-fiction a fiction and sort of a
series of allegorical stories
um otherworldly uh fables if you will
and the reason i did that is that first
i like to tell stories and then i think
a lot of lawyers are are writers who are
scared to go through the apprenticeship
period the cold water flats the
unemployment and what have you that
writers have to
survive
um
but they still have that feeling that
they'd like to write
the other thing that is race is so
controversial that people all have such
they don't have to go to school they all
have deeply felt views based on what
they think is their experience
that in my views my perspective is so
jarring
that to simply state it is is very
upsetting and i find that i have a
better chance of at least being heard if
i can place those views in the context
of a fable of a story during the telling
of which or the reading of which the
individual is able to pull back to not
feel threatened or involved and at least
to kind of see this is something out
there
and people love stories as the success
of the soap opera john reproves
and i feel that they may not agree with
me at the end but at least they have
been able to considering this without
having to make an emotional commitment
uh to it when you read a fact in the
book is it accurate
for the most part i think i at least i
hope so well let me give you for
instance you tell the story about
meeting the white woman in the out in
the
countryside in oregon did you spend time
in oregon yes but the the actual meeting
heard is is not it's not factual it's
all fiction that part is fiction yes so
there's a mix of fact in fiction often
interwoven what you did in 1985 become
the dean of the law school at the
university in 1981
81 yes and i was deemed there for five
years
uh let me go back to this chapter seven
a law pressures professor's protest it
starts off by you saying that um
uh 196 black professors were meeting
with the president of harvard in his
home
and a bomb blew the place up kill them
kill them all right that's not a fact
it's not a fact but the the genesis of
that is that i was the co-chair
of the harvard black faculty and
administrators a group of blacks at uh
uh on on the campus at harvard
and we had decided to do a survey of the
effectiveness of affirmative action
across the campus and we interviewed all
of the deans got all their explanations
wrote them up sent them back and all and
then it was time to write the report and
i said now how can i write a report
that's not going to be read put on the
shelf put in the wastebasket and what
have you
and i decided to create a story
that would illustrate the kind of crisis
out of which
change progress if you will takes place
and i imagine in this story that all of
the faculty the black faculty were
meeting in the president with the
president on a beautiful saturday
afternoon in cambridge
and that suddenly there's this
horrendous explosion and the building
simply vaporizes and of course all of
those who are killed and then that there
of course would be a tremendous
investigation and an awful lot of what
was going to go on there would be
revealed from individuals files and what
they had told their wives or what have
you before they went off to this fatal
meeting
and you i was able through that
methodology to
to tell
all the things the information that
would generally go into a
straightforward report
one of the things i then imagine is that
if the president was going to as a
step in the right direction to issue a
really a positive affirmative action
plan if that kind of information worked
to come out in the wake of such a
tremendous tragedy there would be a
great movement to adopt it as a memorial
to the lost people
and i suggested it was adopted and then
indicate well of course there was not an
explosion but if there had been
this response is likely to have happened
and this response would be appropriate
even if it did if there were not such a
great tragedy and why didn't we do it
and then i sent out this report for the
discussion and what have you well the
president was not pleased
i went to meet with him and he said
why did you do this
and he was sort of sitting like this mr
president this was derek bach
and he said
you don't have to blow me up in order to
make your point you see and that was the
general reaction that they generally i
think they did not get the point
that they did not get the point that
they would have done
willingly
in the wake of a tragedy
as a means of compensation
uh something that would have been
appropriate to do even the absence of
that tragedy which was the reason i told
the story it's actually a
personal thing
you're
it bitterness comes out of the book you
even admit to bitterness in the book uh
it's sometimes the rhetoric is very
angry but when you sit and talk to you
here it's a yeah pleasant conversation
do you deal with people one-on-one like
this or do you deal do you ever get
angry visibly angry in front of them
i sometimes do
i find i'm not as effective
i'm hoping that while i want to be as
honest as i can it's very difficult to
be
in deemed a success
in a society where
thousands early millions of those who
look like you
are
in a situation a life situation than it
that was that is worse than perhaps any
time since
the reconstruction
and feel basically powerless
to do anything about it to see a
presidential campaign going on right now
in which there is for political reasons
rather virtually no mention of the the
kind of uh quasi-genocide
uh that is going on in many of the inner
cities of our of of of our nation
um and so that
uh i'm accosted of being a
you know despairing and to be uh
discouraging young people uh from uh
picking up the picking up the gauntlet
and continuing the struggle
and i guess part of my response is that
i want to discourage
them from
continuing the battle that i fought when
i thought i was fighting as a as a young
as a young lawyer this idea that racism
is
merely an aberration when it's really a
key component because i think we we
fought with the wrong with the wrong
tools maybe we had to do what we did in
order to recognize what i think more of
us recognize now but the other answer i
give is that
uh if if you are not discouraged
uh in in in sense
despair when you look at the condition
of the black community where is maya
angelou who i quote there
indicates that uh
uh young black males particularly see
others like themselves as the worst
enemy
uh that they confront with guns and and
what have you uh then uh i don't think
if you're not discouraged by that and
you're discouraged by my book then then
you need to perhaps reevaluate why
you're why you're despairing back to the
harvard situation you're now visiting
professor at new york university that's
right
how did you leave harvard well i decided
to protest
um the failure to of this faculty to
hire and tenure a woman of color i
throughout my time there i recognized
that the pressures of the students
were a large factor in my being hired
and i've always felt an obligation
to them and to myself as a pioneer to
try to open up the the hiring process
certainly for other people of color but
for whites as well who have
non-traditional qualifications as i did
and i've had some successes and and some
setbacks
i considered it a serious setback that
they were unwilling
to offer a permanent position to a black
woman who i thought had come
and and carried through many of the uh
carried out many of our hopes of what a
a woman of color would be able to do on
that faculty and yet because she didn't
have the credentials
that they wanted because although they
were much better than my credentials
because her writing was not traditional
in a way that they felt writing should
be
they rejected her out of hand
and it was very frustrating for me to
sit there and have
less good credentials to say this is a
person i think
i want you to look at what i've done and
listen to me and give weight to what i
am suggesting and have my suggestions my
recommendations uh simply
dismiss uh to have
black students urging and petitioning
particularly black women urging the
petition that they needed a person like
this and have those petitions rejected
out of hand was very
very upsetting so i decided i wrote a
letter to the dean sent copies to all
the faculty first on a private basis
and said
i can't any longer
pretend that i can be a model for these
women i can't pretend that i can be what
they want
and i'm going to withdraw from the
faculty until you give them what they
have been urging
well i took one year's leave and nothing
happened
i took another year's leave and still
nothing happened
and
the university has a rule limiting
leaves to two consecutive years which i
think is a good rule to make those
who've come down to washington and take
fancy jobs to make a decision whether
they want the faculty position or not i
argue that it should not apply
to my protest which is was a very
different character was in keeping with
what i told them i was going to do when
i when i was hired to continue
pressuring for more diversity in the
hiring process
they didn't agree so
as of june 30 of this year they
terminated my
terminated my position
geneva crenshaw yes who is she geneva is
a
consolidation or a
fictional product of many black women i
have known
my mother
my late wife jewel bell who died two
years ago after 30 years of marriage
constance baker motley the now federal
judge who i assisted in some of the
early cases in in 19 in the
in the early 60s
a number of uh black women i i think
that
they are a marvelous a marvelous group
and very strong very perseverant and my
character has
strangely said superhuman
powers of insight with regard to race i
is the narrator dealing with her take a
more conventional civil rights lawyer
approach we need to continue following
litigation and she tells me that that's
crazy and so is it to provide some
tension
perhaps less so in this book than in my
earlier book that was written along the
same lines in 1987 and we are not saved
now how often when you read her in the
book and you're quoting her is it really
you speaking oh it's always me and it
reflects the ambivalence that i feel and
i think that a lot of blacks feel we're
in this transitional era
in which i can't claim that i have
totally lost my sense that the answer is
one more lawsuit
and one more traditional effort to get
civil rights legislation passed geneva
suggests to me in the book that rather
than our existing civil
anti-discrimination laws we need to pass
a racial preference licensing law
under which those who want to
discriminate as in this restaurant for
example that would go to uh the federal
government office and get a license and
that would say we're not hiring blacks
to be waiters we will admit blacks to be
served but we're not hiring blacks to be
uh
we're only hiring asians to be bus boys
and so on and so on and they then have
to post that uh the license is expensive
maybe a thousand bucks or so um but
they'd have to post that license in a
prominent place so all the public could
see what their policies are and in
addition
a certain percentage of their profits
would have to go into an equality fund
that would be administered by civil
rights leaders to help blacks who wanted
to
build businesses or buy homes and and
what have you
well
uh and on the other hand if they attempt
to discriminate without a license well
the penalties then are very severe sort
of like our rico laws they'd lose the
business and what have you
um
it's not that i really i i argue with
geneva who suggests this plan to me
and i'm not i don't think the idea that
we should seriously
propose such a leg a piece of
legislation but that when we think about
it it is a it is a vehicle for
review of what our present laws do the
fact is that such a law might result in
less discrimination than we now have
under existing laws for a couple of
reasons one is that we see that people
who discriminate like mad
don't want to consider themselves racist
and if they had to post this sign
that would certainly be
the natural
normal conclusion moreover if they had
to pay for their racist
practices that takes a lot of the fun
out of it you see
the reason that they serve me is not
because they either love or hate me
because they see the profit in serving
me they don't see the profit and hiring
blacks who might just might be
unwelcome to some of their other
customers who might be unwelcome to some
of their other employees and so on so
why why do it uh but this provides a
reason to do it so that you might find
at least some
uh
lessening of discriminatory practices
simply by the pressure
with regard that this law would would
provide do you think about or do you see
discrimination or racism every day of
your life
no
no
but i'm i've been insulated i might be
stopped by the police but i know that
because i'm black but i know that when
they before i even reach in my pocket
carefully
uh
that the the
my standard english skills
automatically tell them that they hey
don't don't mess with him you see
i've been stopped in the south
by policemen who are ready to give me
the treatment at least verbally and once
i i always wore my uniform when i was in
the service but even since
once i pull out my wallet and there's
the harvard
officer's card there and what have you
they see that this is and i get almost
deferential uh treatment so that
education and status
economics stuff
poor whites always respect
upper class people you see they may not
like them
but they whether they're black or white
they get a measure of respect
quick story
when i was in louisiana
i wasn't there to challenge you but it
would seem that from what i've been
telling you i decided once beautiful
fall saturday afternoon that i'd love to
go to a football game
and in this little town there was a
small college and they were having a big
game
so going to a football game now i put on
my uniform shined up my bars
went the crowd was going in i parked my
car
and i went over to a policeman
big huge guy and i said officer
are blacks being permitted
to go to this game
he said lieutenant
i don't know but let me find out in this
big huge hawking guy i could see him
above the crowd swirling toward the uh
toured the stadium as he went first to
this window and then somebody sent him
around there kind of almost at a jog
and he finally came back to me he was
kind of walking slow
and he looked
embarrassed
he said
sorry lieutenant
they're not letting you in
they're not letting you in
i thanked him went back to my car and
and went home
but it see that's
that's the kind of thing i get i don't
get the direct uh beating on the heads
that so many of my less
less successful brothers
have to have to deal with
that it's not that we don't face
discrimination but it's a much more of a
mass thing i can go to a dinner party
with upper class professional blocks
and you would think that we were all in
prison
there is rage going around the dinner
table with the beautiful linen and the
handsome
uh cutlery and and silver and what have
you as they talk about one experience
after another that they that they have
gone through in their upper class in
their upper class status you see how
often
do people experience that other blacks
that you know a lot a lot what are the
where do they see the glass ceiling
phenomenon
of the
helping to train others who then get
promoted
over them uh the condescension uh the
unknowing uh slights people don't even
recognize what they are what they are
saying
uh sometimes they're not intended as
that sometimes it's our super
sensitivity
paranoia really
but not all paranoia is without
justification
but it means you really don't feel a
part of it
you see it harvard i think part of my
frustration
was that i played by the rules
i was determined that
notwithstanding that i was the first
black notwithstanding the fact that i
didn't have the traditional credentials
that i was going to become a better
teacher than most of them and i think i
did that i was going to become a more
noted scholar than most of them and i
think i did
and yet i
never became part of the family i was
never really accepted as as as one of
them so while that i had the status
and the pay and the opportunity to teach
some very very impressive students of
all races
i was never part of the family and
that's a that can be a very destructive
thing over time do you have any heroes
yeah
i think other people who stand up
and take risk
judge hasty who i may have mentioned
earlier who during world war ii left a
very plush position with the uh
with the department of army because he
was frustrated about the lack of
effort to end discrimination in the
in the service
next week on book notes our guest is
retired general norman schwarzkopf he
joins us to discuss his autobiography it
doesn't take a hero
that's next sunday on book notes at 8 00
and 11 pm eastern time
coming next a live news conference from
little rock arkansas with members of the
congressional democratic leadership who
met with president-elect bill clinton
last night
[Music]
this program is part of c-span's
a day